all right here we go
hmm what is happening what did they do
we're gonna come from where to go where
the [ __ ] did the video go I'm Annie man
I'm not [ __ ] are we are we alive are we
back
are we good did something happen are we
still is everything oh god why is that
like that why is it doing that stop
doing that
zombie in a silly [ __ ] for one goddamn
second okay holy [ __ ] okay
I got Mickey Mouse hands oh god there's
just dicks under here my man whoa I got
grabby hands what's the first thing I'm
gonna do diddily live [ __ ] you oh that's
nice that's nice oh that's nice okay so
what about this what am I supposed to do
mmm I really grabbed that ball [ __ ] you
whoo that was a responsive flung yeah
wow that's actually accurate you know
it's accurate cuz I can't hit for [ __ ]
Oh Ariel what's it filled up candy head
lice yeah dreams [ __ ] huh everything my
home enjoys barf Junko mad margul angry
more go one pain Norco one pain for
anime Marco whoa whoa wait whoa oh I
didn't know oh god it's so flirty
oh god that's too much flood oh god my
users need pump it's I'm pumping as hard
as I can
huh
ah that was so weird you're gonna get
both cannons now no no please
Oh God ah yep that's what you deserve
that's actually cool what happens when I
fluid simulations nice splat clown
painter not pretty sure that's not at a
pretty sure that is about hanging those
clowns until they explode all over their
faces
what yeah there's no way to not take
this sexually blood I suppose if you
were you know not an immature 27 year
old blah but how else am I supposed to
do this hey [ __ ] hey [ __ ] the clown
you want some of this
ah oh you showed having him you're next
ah I was an illusion
he was next Oh see you're all dead now
we're all cheaters now what ah
it's st. Patrick's Day oh oh they're all
out of balloons okay what do we got
whoo-hoo I know how to do this woo notch
it not oh [ __ ] it up yeah [ __ ] that's
less powerful than I thought
huh get up yeah [ __ ] you up [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
these are real arrows [ __ ] you whoo [ __ ]
huh boink huh huh bonk
kept Cabo ink tap wait are these only
worth one point apiece whoo [ __ ] fire
him
whoa [ __ ] look at that oh I got a foe I
gotta let him on fighting no I gotta
light him on fire how was I supposed to
know oh well I'm gonna repeat that I
want that one can I get another but I
have another may I have another someone
in the distance gonna get some you get
lit on fire all right fine [ __ ] you what
do you got for me
whoa ah [ __ ] up oh oh wow wow wow
yeah my unbridled aggression finally
released in the form of I'm the next
Hokage worship my name
I don't want snort oh okay now that I'm
sufficiently out of breath I got my
exercise in for the day move on what are
you up for me oh hey Wacom below will
take that [ __ ] sorry [ __ ] do with
your stupid hair your stupid hair is
dumb I hate it whoa you wanna holy [ __ ]
ah hey ah ha ha ha the hair is so
weirdly real ha oh [ __ ]
43 I should have been hitting from the
flat side oh chunk not happy Marco why
more [ __ ] you brutal on come on me ha
you a Maronite ah [ __ ] you [ __ ] off
[ __ ]
who do you think you got midnight Wow
[ __ ] off yeah yeah yeah
I can't think up a little
I got a little wet [ __ ] you don't laugh
at me ha ha
[ __ ] awful even for you yeah shut up a
[ __ ] you think you're gone that night
huh I have fun um oh I don't even need
to look yeah yeah what ha ha yeah yo yo
whoa oh wow don't do it I don't know
throw coming at me real coming everyone
down
whoa Gordana hey hey hey hey hey baby
herself boys boys yeah
man who knew the minions game would be
so much fun
hey hey say banana yeah say banana hey
say the thing come on say banana oh come
on it's my favorite line bahnana bahnana
bahnana bahnana Brandon nah I wouldn't
be shocked if that was copyrighted what
is that oh [ __ ] I was just playing the
Brookhaven experiment Oh shooting from
the hips come on a cowboy I'm cowboy a
big wad hips Anna birthing labia I don't
know a cowboy [ __ ] you in the face then
go suck a dick oh oh yes I dark I I
guess we're done whoa
cannon skeet oh I don't like the sound
of that one without weirdly sexual whoa
boink
yeah whoa ah got it oh yeah boom Punk
I am so good oh man look at me I like
legitimately I've been I've been making
fun of this a lot and and having a good
time with this but the fact that this
exists is really frickin cool whoa [ __ ]
this is breaking it on its own too many
fragments like legitimately this is just
cool the fact that this technology this
feels real
see it freakin feels real that's so
weird
that's so weird that's so weird then
feels real my god it's awesome
that's friggin awesome I figured awesome
oh [ __ ]
oh my score I guess I'm done oh man
those fun well this was my score two in
clown painter not very good I didn't
know what I was doing for and fire
Archer I wasn't ready
375 in balloon Knight 43 in whack-a-mole
94 in boxing 33 in shooting gallery 42
in cannon skeet
so that is all for now this was oh hey
how's it going
this was doodles and oodles of fun I had
a blast playing this this was a ton of
minigames but still it's the most
immersive VR experience I've had yet
weirdly because the graphical technology
was there like it's obviously made by
Nvidia so of course they're gonna show
off with their fluid physics and hair
stuff but it added a level of realism
that I don't often get with these games
so it was really fun so if you have a
vibe play this one beat my high score if
you can but thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought in the comments down below
thanks again for watching and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
and expe howl back on the give me your
giant nose Oh
float like a butterfly just like a beam